all right so it was a Raymond yeah
Raymond where do grow up free from I
grew up in Los Angeles Watts you know
all my life basically until I went to
the youth 2:30 at the age of 12 you know
and then at the age of 12 actually lost
my mom's toe - I was 12 years old and I
lost my mom when I was in the Youth
Authority and and at that point I think
I just lost it all because losing her
was like the only thing I had you know
and when she passed it it took
everything from me and so I ended up
doing five and a half years in the Youth
Authority so I mean I tore up everything
because of the pain I couldn't had
nobody to talk to nobody to confide in
so Youth Authority is what it's for
California - that is for the youth like
from 12 to 17 who ends up there people
who commit crimes like kids your car
robbery GTA yeah I got caught the same
day same [ __ ] now
haha you saw her yeah yeah yeah I see
that's what I mean I didn't have the
guidance in my house there was my father
was a drug addict my mother was an
alcoholic and in that sense there was
nobody to control me or or tell me so I
followed the footsteps of everybody else
that was in the street I was looking for
something and I ran to the streets and
nobody ever told me that the streets
would take me under you know I was a kid
like right and so I did what they did
looking for a big brother or a father
figure looking for some kind of family
and and that wasn't there and so I was
in the streets all my I've been in the
streets all my life like
I'm still in the streets and it's it's
crazy because the streets want me to use
the drugs and and it's crazy because
like the drugs like I never like like
looking back I never would have expected
my life to be in a [ __ ] like it's a
real [ __ ] it's a real [ __ ] [ __ ] all
night late I use crystal meth crack
cocaine PCP I've been out here late
you know and and thinking that was cool
it was the only way I had and so even
when you know the way is bad it's the
only way you have in this [ __ ] it's
like [ __ ] you know I do what I got to
do and like all I was doing was chasing
my tail all I was doing was chasing my
tail it's [ __ ] amazing you know I've
been on everybody knows everybody your
boy know everybody knows me because when
I was out here it was go to work get it
I don't give a damn how I got to get up
in a lot of you I'm finna tell you this
big old story Hey look check this out my
boy he got this he got this you would
give me your money I would take your
money I would have fake dope in my
pocket I would say I'll be right back I
was running around the corner would take
the funk dope on my pocket by the real
dope watch you smoke this fake dope oh
man he got us I believe with the real
dope in my pocket that's scheming I was
a schemer like any means necessary I
didn't give a [ __ ] you smoked it that's
yogurt but it was to feed my habit it
was take like that monster like that
monster was a [ __ ] that monster
is a [ __ ] and I guess to this
day I'm still dealing with that monster
you know because I try I think like
okay not today you know not today not
today but it could be any day you know
I'm an addict I'm a recovering addict if
that's what you want to call it but who
I think I call it a process because I'm
still going through the [ __ ] out here
I'm still out here you know I'm still
out here Eddie
I think it's it's hope is faith it's
this right here this key on my neck it
says faith and that's the key right
there that's the key man that's the key
the key is faith even though I'm still
in this bond this tight rope around my
neck I believe that I believe I can make
it like I ain't made it yet but I
believe that if I keep doing what I'm
doing and stay focused I'm you know
trying to stay focus out here is it's
crazy because I still look back on the
things that I lost and I still look back
it still I don't know how I still carry
this I don't know why I still carry the
song I don't know why I do but there's
some some things you can't let go up
like us me as a person I don't know why
I hold on to things you know I'm saying
I hold on the [ __ ] that did that that's
hard to let go and I think I do it
because the trauma had put me through
years in the situation the [ __ ] that I
went through and these episodes kind of
like you can't let this go I can't let
this go because it hurts so much it's
like a scar you know you got a score and
you can still look at your arm or your
body and still see that scar and the
reflection of the scar like how I got
that scar that's sort of like the things
I hold on to you know the things I hold
on until I got a daughter I haven't seen
in years because of my life and your
streams you know I'm saying my life is
just my daughters about to be 14 you
know I've been in prison
you know and every time I got out of
prison I went back to prison
I went back to prison because I remember
this I used to sit up in prison right
before I got out I said yeah I'm finna
go get a quarter pink so I'm gonna go
get some dope I finished rinsing that I
got that up right off to the race I
never thought about my daughter I never
thought about her I never thought about
her well-being I never thought about she
need a father I never thought about that
and she's gonna be 14 and it's amazing
that you know I changed but I feel like
it's it's too late you know as a father
it's too late I mean you got a chance to
make something I have a chance to make
some things up and get some things right
but then again I look at you can't make
nothing up you can't fix what you can't
fix what's broken you just take these
pieces and put them together and work
with him like in and you know my baby
mama she got a I believe she have the
reason for some of the things she do
like keeping my daughter at a distance
uh you know keeping her at a distance
but it's it's not fair to me at this
point being that I changed but nobody
will see your change nobody will see the
process you go through to change nobody
sees that all they see is you this you
you know he goes to jail he's in and out
of prison you know he can't stop selling
drugs using drugs he can't stop people
put that he can't stop me and I think
it's my fault it's my fault and so that
goes back to what I was saying about
that score my fault you know I'm saying
every time I look at it and it's it
[ __ ] me up but I mean mentally it [ __ ]
me up because I have to deal with it you
know I wish I mean there's so many
things I wish I wish I could take back
you know I wish I but you can't change
what's already out there like like you
know every day I get up and fight not to
go back to me you know I'm saying every
day I get up and I find you know I want
to you know money money money that's
that seems like it makes everybody happy
much yeah so now I'm learning like money
is not it it's not the material things
that that that dissatisfied people I
mean these only temporary things that
this money temporary don't satisfy you
at the end of the day when the money's
gone
then what so I think like that but then
it's like [ __ ] you need that money you
need them because that money satisfies
everybody else and it seems like we
trying to say we as people try to
satisfy it cuz we need people you know
we need people in this it's like [ __ ]
how far am I willing to go to satisfy
someone else when you look at it that's
why I say money's not important that's
another point that says that money is
it's not it's not what you need you know
what you need is is its compassion you
know what you need is understanding what
you need is somebody that can talk to
you you can talk to without all the
agendas you know hidden agendas you know
I'm only [ __ ] with you cuz you got
some money I'm only [ __ ] with you cuz
you get some money I see a lot of that a
lot of that you know years you've been
doing it rough
just 2000 just took tout twenty years
I've been down here 20 years
sleeping in tents sidewalks [ __ ] not
without a tent you know I'm saying I
would [ __ ] run to any one of these
spots with all these clothes and see a
bunch of bums out I'm feeling asleep
right here I'm gonna fall asleep right
here on the street that what led I mean
when I look back at that [ __ ] I'm like
wow I can't believe how how I lost
myself but then I can I can't because
being a realist I say that because of
the drugs and the chasing that I did was
the distractions all these were
distractions from me being focused on
doing something but I think that these
distractions were put there for me to
see that there were distractions you
know I mean I lost everything I lost
everything like you know I have no
relationship with anyone I mean my
family stays in fontana san bernardino
and all that and Here I am stuck in LA
with no support I am my only support
system the last time you saw your family
[ __ ] mm mm 2012 there's some [ __ ] like
that it's been a while you know I got
nieces and nephews I haven't even seen I
got cousins dead I don't even know you
know I'll get on Facebook now and I meet
people I don't even know what it is but
they related to me somehow someway and
it [ __ ] me up because you family and I
don't even know that you know what do
you think it is it keeps you down here
what keeps you down here
haha wiki's I actually I'm gonna say I
love down here because of the the [ __ ]
that I went through you know and and and
all the trouble that I went through it
started down it it started down here so
I figure why why leave here when you
become better as a person you can leave
but it's this right here that made me
you know I'm saying it's it's all these
scars down here to keep me down here
it's all the scars
it's all the scars they only had to keep
you down here I can't get rid of these
cars you feel like you belong here yeah
yeah yeah I mean this is Miss skiros
downtown Skid Row man [ __ ] I mean you
can get robbed you could kill anything
can happen down here and why do I still
put myself in that situation I guess
because it doesn't bother me you know it
would bother someone else to come down
here and look at this [ __ ] and be like
what the [ __ ] it would bother somebody
it's a lot of people don't even come
down here because of this but when you
look at this if you actually get a
chance to look at this you'll see that
it's not it's not that bad it's not the
place it's the people and that's just
what it is and if it's the people dinner
people got to change not the place you
can't change the places to people that
gotta change and I'm one of those
persons one of those people they
actually had the chance to see that like
you can't keep doing the same [ __ ] over
and over you can't keep being like I see
it I used to sit up in prison say yeah
I'm gonna get out sell this dope on
madhu desist but when I opened my eyes I
was right there and that jail said I was
still laying on that bunk and that part
of reality hit me like you son of a
[ __ ]
your son with this so you're gonna keep
doing this and when I say this I mean
coming back to prison you don't keep
doing this keep doing it and you'll keep
getting the same [ __ ]
it's hard it's very hard to change
change is hard because most people don't
want to change we are comfortable I'm
comfortable in this [ __ ] and that's just
what he is [ __ ] I'm comfortable winning
I'm comfortable that's the crazy part
about it that's the crazy part about it
when you realize when you sit back and
you start to see this [ __ ] for this I'm
comfortable in this [ __ ] that's that's
insanity okay how did you get to
insanity how did you get to this point I
got to this point because I got lost I
got lost I got distracted
yeah I got distracted but I allowed
myself to be distracted and it's amazing
how you slippin and [ __ ] like like
you're not ready for the game don't step
in again period don't if you got family
and [ __ ] they love you and stick stick
with that mean first it's people like
gotta realize you got to love yourself
there is nobody that's gonna love you
greater than you and we forget that we
forget that because we get so distracted
in what we got going on I need some
company all company ain't good company
all company I'm still learning that all
company ain't good company there's
people out here today
I'll be waiting I'd be like damn you
loud you hella just disrespect you just
you're not my cup of tea now I'm
starting to see that it's the cup in the
team in this it's what you put you if I
hang around [ __ ] then I'm a track
[ __ ] even though I don't do the
[ __ ] all the [ __ ] I hang around
will surround me all the [ __ ]
I'm still here like it's it's a story
that I want to tell because it's a story
that somebody has to hear like my story
could help somebody else take some
pieces from this story in in in put it
in and put it in your story so you don't
make the same mistakes I made I've been
in the streets my whole life like gang
banging and all I like all of it was
supported the destruction you know I'm
saying like like really [ __ ] like
like I'm 40 years old I'm about to be 41
and I have 20 from 12 teen what's that
20 some years and I've been down here 20
years so you can see the the fall you
can see the the [ __ ] man you can see all
the years I lost and I could see all the
years I lost and so I step on that I use
that as a stepping stone you know I'm
saying it and I use it a stepping stone
to help somebody else out because to me
that's what life is about like even in a
situation what they say it's not where
you went it's about what you about it's
about you and I I know now that see
either you can be a builder or you gonna
be a destroyer you can help somebody up
or you can pull somebody down that's
either that's either there's only two
things you're gonna do in life but you
make that choice you make that choice
and it goes back to the choice I made
that's what I look way back to the
choices on me to the choices I made wait
my god
do you know it's is my it's heavy on the
mind because I want to say I lost but I
didn't lose you know
you know it take it take a loss
sometimes they take a loss for you to
gain something sometimes you got to lose
this to get to this and no matter what
like all that know what's gonna happen
next
I'm still on parole you know I'm saying
I'm still on parole going through the
[ __ ] I'm going through and I'm still
trying to make it like like but I
probably wouldn't have the heart or the
courage to make it to understand it if I
wasn't down here if it wasn't for
rock-bottom if it I probably never got
up you know I probably never got up if
it wasn't for this [ __ ] right here you
know I know all the drug addicts I know
all the dealers I know everybody but
that don't mean I have to be part of it
I don't have to be part of it and that's
by choice like it's always the choice
it's a choice it's a choice and looking
at those choices I also look at the
repercussion of choices so you got to
see in advance and that's why I'm
telling my story because I hope my story
helps somebody see in advance you know
tattoos battle wounds all that [ __ ]
still I still have a mentality where I
go hard I I have to go hard though I
have to go home because I'm not giving
no pass since I'm very serious about my
recovery I'm very serious about getting
ahead in life and when I left all this
[ __ ] alone I cut it off you know that's
how I am as a person when I make my mind
up to do something that's it
cuz I'm all I got I'm all I got I don't
just like I said you can have family
members but support support that's
important
I'm poor how important do you think not
having a father in your life was very I
mean my father was he couldn't give me
the support or the love or [ __ ] that
that most kids have you know and it was
very important because I needed a father
figure
I needed that man I needed that
you know teach me and since I didn't had
that teach me I went to the streets and
the streets talking and it's crazy you
know but I still talk to my pops now I
just talked to him yesterday we like
this week but I tried to forgive you
know I forgive my father for not
understanding how to be a father I
forgive my father for for it foot like I
said my not understanding that he
probably didn't have that cuz he was in
the streets you know and so I look back
to say well maybe he didn't have that
structure that guy used to give to me
and as you gonna always love your father
your mother you're gonna always love
your people and so you know it's very
important to have a father figure a
parent figure you know a solid
foundation and that's why I say I'm very
serious about what I'm serious about
because I'm setting a foundation and I
refuse I refuse to go back works you
know I'm saying I don't know is the
story in the Bible this is that I forget
it to give us life where the prophecy
came and told him to leave the village
because we're gonna burn this thing down
we finna destroyed his village
and the wife he told me take your wife
and your kids and get out you know the
wife was like not on it but she left and
when they went up the mountains when
they got past these hills and out the
village she looked back and she turned
into a pillar of salt so that more or
that story is more like when you start
moving to here don't look back don't
look back that's my food don't look back
cuz she looked back and she turned into
a pillar of salt for looking back when
you told you to go ahead you look back
and that's stirring that bottle like
like that sticks to me like because I
could be that pillar of salt looking
back I've been that you know over and
over 20 years I've been here 20 years
see I'm tired of being that pillar if
I'm gonna be a pillar I'm gonna be a
positive pillar you know I'm saying I'm
gonna be something you can stand on I'm
gonna be something you could take
something from you know that's just I'm
very serious about this like very
serious about my recovery and when I say
recovery I'm not just talking about as
an addict I'm talking about as a person
because you get so caught up in this
addiction out here this this lifestyle
that you lose everything who want to be
a loser we want to be a loser and so I
think that that I'm blessed to be able
to tell my story and and see it I'm able
to see it so I hope somebody else to see
it you know
you know I mean I'm the type of person
that I'll help you would whatever you
need help with if I if I can help you
I'll help you because that's what I feel
life is about life is about helping
people now not not the same well you
know I got this and taken something from
you that's that's the problem sometimes
you take so much you got two hands and
your hands are full from taking what do
you have to give you can't give nothing
because you even took so much that you
you're so used to taking that you can't
give a handout that's not that's that's
you know for every man you come to a
point in life where it's like [ __ ] I got
to start giving I got to start giving to
get you gotta give see cuz if you'd
never give you'll never get I promise
you that I promise you that if you never
give you never get and [ __ ] it's crazy
because all the scars that I have and
I'm still able to give like [ __ ] I'm
able to I'm able to forgive I think
that's like I really forgiveness is the
biggest part of anything you got to
forgive yourself first though
you got to forgive yourself cuz if you
can't forgive you then you can't forgive
nobody else you know it's like people
may have played a part in the things
that cause you to be who you are but
when you really look back on that [ __ ]
you could say okay well though this was
a piece that did that I say that made me
do the [ __ ] that I did actually I did it
because I did it I did it you didn't
make me do what I did I did that you
know
and so now I just hope they're lifelike
like I know life I don't hope because I
don't like used hoping like when you're
moving ahead in life and you're doing
positive [ __ ] positive things happen I
mean you can't go wrong doing right you
can't go wrong doing right and you know
and I heard about you mark so I want to
come here and tell my story because
there's so many people who need somebody
inference some kind of there's so many
people who need somebody else story to
fix a story you know and and I just hope
that my story can help somebody else
fixed a story they never care like I
said man it's Keys faith it's faith man
and that's what I live by now I live by
faith you know I live by faith like
faith in me faith in and doing positive
if it's like it's just about faith I
think faith brought me to this day no
but
it is what it is all right thank you so
much for coming out
yeah thank you great hey god bless Shaw
you